hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well
in truth and lying in an extra moral
sense there comes a point in the essay
where Friedrich Nietzsche is going to
ask this age-old question one that has
bedeviled so many people what is truth
it's one of those terms that we throw
around quite a bit but you know if we
have to be put on the spot and say
precisely what it is we often find
ourselves in perplexities and
difficulties it's one that philosophers
have spent a lot of time on produced a
lot of interesting theories about it's
also one that those who are in power and
perhaps cynical or perhaps quizzical may
ask as Pilate did during the trial of
Jesus he asked what is truth right and
we don't go any further than that
in the story the idea is that he's
supposed to you know be disparaging
truth or he has no idea what it is but
Nietzsche thinks that that most of us
don't actually have any sort of handle
on truth and he's telling us a story
about the generation of the distinction
between truth and lying and it's
consolidation leading us all the way up
to like you know notions of science and
natural law and issues like that that he
thinks at bottom really are matters of
dissimilation and deception the the
opposite of truth is we portray it so
you know what is Nietzsche contrasting
his own view here we're gonna get to
this really famous passage where truth
is a mobile army of metaphors in just a
moment the closest that you could say we
have to Ameche in' theory of truth
before that let's think a little bit
about what what other people have indeed
said in a much more optimistic way the
truth would be you know that which
perhaps we understood it as reality that
which when we take our own selves out of
the equation and our own subjective you
know bias
and intentions that's the residue that
we're left with the the stuff that that
resists our own interpretation of it and
thereby impresses itself upon us so the
truth has been conceptualized sometimes
as that which remains self same or that
which can be justified and explained you
know if we're thinking about the
Socratic treatment of truth another
common way of understanding it is some
sort of correspondence or add equation
between different things between thought
and reality between language and the
things between our concepts and things
as they genuinely are in themselves or
if we're talking about the truth of our
own concepts that we we adequately
understand what's going on in our own
minds and from Nietzsche's perspective
this is really highly optimistic
optimistic in the pejorative sense of
being out of touch with with with
reality and that he's going to talk
about other people have closely
associated truth with goodness this
isn't something that you'll not only
find within various religious traditions
but also even every once in a while
somebody like Aristotle
will slip something in there and lying
is something that's bad right
Nietzsche's gonna tell us something very
different and I'm going to read this
passage and then we'll explain it bit by
bit so he says what is truth in such a
beautiful way of describing it after
that a mobile army of metaphors metonym
anthropomorphisms in short a sum of
human relations which were poetically
and rhetorically heightened transferred
and adorned and after long you seem
solid canonical and binding to a nation
so that seems almost like a definition
doesn't it and it reads almost like that
that sort of phrase what is truth truth
is here's the linguistic expression
Nietzsche is doing something
performative in saying this he's already
engaging in metaphor and metonymy and
probably anthropomorphism in his
explanation of what truth is so let's
talk about each of these terms a little
bit what is a metaphor in its broadest
sense a metaphor is a way of using
languages or signs linguistic signs in
which one thing stands in for another so
if we talk about rosy-fingered dawn for
example rosy finger that epithet is a
metaphor obviously dawn doesn't have
fingers and what's rosie about it is I
suppose the color and the hue as dawn is
approaching right that's also an
anthropomorphism as well the taking of
natural phenomena and making it into
something like a human being with with
presence with with you know it's a
agency something that we can pin things
upon metaphors right metaphors are one
thing for another I am a bear in the
morning if I have not yet had my coffee
I'm not literally a bear right so we
might say not truthfully a bear right
and if we're using this correspondence
thing but metaphorically how am I like
it there
well I growl at people and maybe I
should to say I'm a hyena because I bark
at people instead
but even that notice there's a metaphor
going on there do I literally bark no I
say things in a brown abrupt way we call
that barking all right what is a
metonymy or here translated metonym
metonymy is a similar to metaphor
there's a kind of transference of sense
but you're you're working generally with
part whole or part part relations so you
know one famous metonymy is where we use
sails to talk about
ships because the sail is a part of a
ship or are we talk about you know there
were 500 Spears at the battle meaning
500 men carried Spears into fight at the
battle obviously the Spears didn't just
like go off on their own like some you
know thing and The Sorcerer's Apprentice
it was dabbing people left and right no
they were there carried by other people
and so metonym czar very similar to
metaphors although a lot of a lot of
theorists would like to draw a
distinction between them answer morphism
like I said is when you are treating
something that's not human as if it was
human you know most of our cartoons
about animals are great examples of
anthropomorphisms we you know think
about some of these these funny things
that come up you know why is it that
some dogs in Disney movies get to wear
pants and others are on leashes right
some have been more anthropomorphised
than others so Nietzsche is saying that
truth itself is not something outside of
the metaphor outside of the metonym
outside of the anthropomorphism rather
truth is this that's the basis of truth
and he goes on to say I didn't put this
on the board but he goes on to say that
these after long-used seem solid
canonical and binding to a nation to a
community to a set of language users so
very often things can ring true to us if
we're from one community where they
might not ring true to another now he
doesn't stop there and another way that
he talks about truth following up on
this is that truths are illusions that
we no longer realize to be illusions
they have been forgotten as illusions
notice that he's going to use metaphor
in doing this he goes down and he says
their coin
which have lost their image and now can
be used only as metal and no longer as
coins right that's a metaphor for verbal
transactions so he's using truth in the
sense of metaphor to get at truth in
terms of metaphor and after a while our
metaphors lose their their sort of force
they are no longer so striking or the
metonym we just go along with it right
really if you think about the the
innards of your computer or your phone
and all the ways in which we describe
technology we use a lot of these things
metaphors and and metonym and we do
anthropomorphize our computers as well
it's the way we wrap our head around it
and it doesn't take that long it's only
taken you know essentially one
generation or a generation and a half
for us to call a little slab of stuff
that we move around a mouse and totally
lose any sort of connection between that
and you know the old notion of mouse is
something with a tail and and the thing
that we now call a mouse as a matter of
fact there's probably many people that
other than cartoons have never seen a
mouse in their life and they've seen
lots of computer mice another classic
example of this is if you if you see
that little disc icon in your word you
know processor or whatever other program
you're using that's that's a visual
metaphor right it's it's showing you a
disk and it's also a metonymy because
it's talking about the action of saving
something it's identifying the look of
the thing with its function now for many
children they've never seen a floppy
disk or one of those little harder
floppy discs in their life they probably
never will but the symbol still remains
and the symbol has its meaning because
it is conventional that is what nature
says truth
consists in he also talks about society
as treating truth as something that can
be imposed upon us as an obligation so
he says that we you know we don't know
where the desire for truth originates
but we've heard only of the obligation
which society in order to exist imposes
to be truthful if we don't if we're not
truthful to each other
we can't have society right and society
tells us to be truthful so we're not
like those Liars who he pushed out or
punished he says what does this mean to
use the customary metaphors or in moral
terms the obligation to lie according to
an established Convention to lie
collectively in a style that is
mandatory for everyone now this is
something that we come to desire
Nietzsche says we not only have this
imposed upon us by however society is
going to work in order for it to
continue to function we come to desire
truth as something that we view as good
as useful for us as something that has
value in itself so he goes on and he
says we forget that this is the
situation so he lies in the designated
manner unconsciously and according to
centuries-old habits
precisely by this unconsciousness by
this forgetting he arrives at his sense
of truth the sense of being obliged by
society by language by convention to
call one thing read another cold a third
one mute give gives rise he says to a
moral feeling with respect to truth it
becomes something that we desire that we
impose upon ourselves we treat being
truthful as what it is that we ought to
do as what makes us good and those other
people who don't do it as bad when at
bottom truth really is as Nietzsche is
telling us in his his view a mobile army
of metaphors maddinames
anthropomorphisms etc etc right and it's
something that society can impose
precisely because there's been the
sedimentation of habit going on us in
many cases for centuries although as
they pointed out it can happen very
quickly as new conventions arise so this
is a very challenging conception of
truth isn't it it's very much at odds
with the notion of truth is a
correspondence between mind and thing or
words and and realities if this is right
this implies that all of those notions
of truth would really be off base
you